This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,|||这是 I-Heart 播客。必属真人出品。在《回顾往昔》(Look Back at It) 播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。1984年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格lish。在每一集中，我们都会选择一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the Outer. My Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the Outer. My Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.|||并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊20世纪80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。在 Outer。My Heart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn. Learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn. Learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.|||嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《吃一堑长一智》(Learn the Hard Way)，我是你们最喜欢的心理治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全、无法进行的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，听听就知道。在 AHA 电台应用、Apple Podcast 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《吃一堑长一智》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in selling, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in selling, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.|||但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你在售卖过程中伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。成群结队的互联网侦探才揭露了一个令人不安的模式。还有两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉勒斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
this is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%.
this is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%.|||这是《陷入爱河的陷阱》(Love Trapped)。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在 IHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《陷入爱河的陷阱》播客。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners,
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners,|||我剖析了我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是 IHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方的 TWA%。大家好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》(The Psychology of Your 20s)，这是一个探讨我们在20多岁时经历的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎新听众回到播客，
old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you back for another episode. Today, we're going to be talking about anger, one of our most primal human emotions that I think gets neglected a lot in our conversations around mental health and kind of the spectrum of feelings that we have every day. Anger is such a, I think, think a hidden, private experience for a lot of us, something to be kind of concealed behind politeness and niceties, something to be suppressed. You know, we're told that it's a very ugly emotion, something that needs to be controlled and then it holds us back. And I think, yes, maybe that is true, but anger is also a really important emotional cue. And it also shows up
old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you back for another episode. Today, we're going to be talking about anger, one of our most primal human emotions that I think gets neglected a lot in our conversations around mental health and kind of the spectrum of feelings that we have every day. Anger is such a, I think, think a hidden, private experience for a lot of us, something to be kind of concealed behind politeness and niceties, something to be suppressed. You know, we're told that it's a very ugly emotion, something that needs to be controlled and then it holds us back. And I think, yes, maybe that is true, but anger is also a really important emotional cue. And it also shows up|||老听众，无论你身处世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能回来收听新的一期节目。今天，我们要聊的是愤怒，这是人类最原始的情绪之一，我认为它在我们关于心理健康以及我们每天拥有的各种情绪的讨论中经常被忽视。愤怒对我来说，我认为对我们很多人来说，是一种隐藏的、私密的体验，是一种被隐藏在礼貌和客套背后、需要被压抑的东西。你知道的，我们被告知这是一种非常丑陋的情绪，是一种需要被控制、进而会阻碍我们前进的东西。我想，是的，也许这是真的，但愤怒也是一个非常重要的情绪信号。它也会出现在
in a lot of our daily interactions. We are angry at a friend for letting us down, at a co-worker for messing something up or a partner for a past mistake that we just can't let go of. There is a lot of invisible anger inside, I think a lot of us, anger that lives below the surface and probably has done for a long time. And like I said, we're really good at accepting our kind of pretty and romanticized emotions like happiness or even grief, even melancholy, but rage and fury, they seem to be left out. And I think I spent quite a lot of time, quite a few years, in my early 20s, kind of ruled by anger, in ways that I didn't realize. I was angry at the world. I was angry at people who had overlooked me or hurt me or who had been cruel to me, because really, it was easier to feel anger than admit
in a lot of our daily interactions. We are angry at a friend for letting us down, at a co-worker for messing something up or a partner for a past mistake that we just can't let go of. There is a lot of invisible anger inside, I think a lot of us, anger that lives below the surface and probably has done for a long time. And like I said, we're really good at accepting our kind of pretty and romanticized emotions like happiness or even grief, even melancholy, but rage and fury, they seem to be left out. And I think I spent quite a lot of time, quite a few years, in my early 20s, kind of ruled by anger, in ways that I didn't realize. I was angry at the world. I was angry at people who had overlooked me or hurt me or who had been cruel to me, because really, it was easier to feel anger than admit|||我们的许多日常互动中。我们对一个让我们失望的朋友感到愤怒，对一个把事情搞砸的同事或对一个我们无法释怀的过去错误的伴侣感到愤怒。我认为我们许多人内心都积压了大量无形的愤怒，这种愤怒潜藏在水面之下，可能已经存在很长时间了。就像我说的，我们非常擅长接受那些美好且被浪漫化的情绪，比如快乐，甚至是悲伤，甚至是忧郁，但暴怒和狂怒似乎被排斥在外了。我想我在20多岁出头的很长一段时间里，很多年里，在某种程度上被愤怒所统治，而我自己却没有意识到。我对这个世界感到愤怒。我对那些忽视我、伤害我或对我残酷的人感到愤怒，因为说实话，相比于承认
how insecure those experiences had made me. And I think I thought that being angry almost made me tough. And I let that feeling really make a lot of decisions for me. I let it be projected onto people who didn't deserve that. I let it turn to misery. And I wish that I'd known when I know now. So let's share everything to do with the psychology behind anger and what psychology has to say about this misguided and misjudged feeling. I feel like we don't need a definition of anger. Every human, even every animal knows the feeling, the hot feeling, the pressure in the chest, the twitching hands, that kind of building urge to react and to scream. Anger is one of our most primal, rudimentary emotions.
how insecure those experiences had made me. And I think I thought that being angry almost made me tough. And I let that feeling really make a lot of decisions for me. I let it be projected onto people who didn't deserve that. I let it turn to misery. And I wish that I'd known when I know now. So let's share everything to do with the psychology behind anger and what psychology has to say about this misguided and misjudged feeling. I feel like we don't need a definition of anger. Every human, even every animal knows the feeling, the hot feeling, the pressure in the chest, the twitching hands, that kind of building urge to react and to scream. Anger is one of our most primal, rudimentary emotions.|||那些经历让我变得多么没有安全感，去感受愤怒要容易得多。我想我曾以为愤怒几乎让我变得坚强。我让那种感觉真正为我做了很多决定。我让它投射到那些不值得这样对待的人身上。我让它变成了一种痛苦。我希望我当时就知道我现在所知道的。所以让我们分享所有与愤怒背后的心理学相关的内容，以及心理学对这种被误导和误判的情绪的看法。我觉得我们不需要给愤怒下定义。每个人，甚至每只动物都知道这种感觉，那种灼热的感觉，胸口的压迫感，抽搐的手，那种不断积聚的想要做出反应和尖叫的冲动。愤怒是我们最原始、最基本的情绪之一。
It is an emotion that mobilizes the body for action. It mobilizes our fight or flight response. And that is what means that it allows us to survive in response to a perceived threat or a perceived injustice. These kinds of primal emotions always really fascinate me because we, We have evolved so much from being these creatures who are only ruled and driven by survival and instinct. We're no longer out hunting in the wilderness or fighting, you know, neighboring tribes. Maybe we are in some senses, but our society has really evolved to make sure we are all kind of prim and proper and we are suppressing these really raw emotions and yet they're still there.
It is an emotion that mobilizes the body for action. It mobilizes our fight or flight response. And that is what means that it allows us to survive in response to a perceived threat or a perceived injustice. These kinds of primal emotions always really fascinate me because we, We have evolved so much from being these creatures who are only ruled and driven by survival and instinct. We're no longer out hunting in the wilderness or fighting, you know, neighboring tribes. Maybe we are in some senses, but our society has really evolved to make sure we are all kind of prim and proper and we are suppressing these really raw emotions and yet they're still there.|||它是一种调动身体采取行动的情绪。它调动了我们的战斗或逃跑反应。这就是为什么它能让我们通过应对感知到的威胁或感知到的不公来生存。这类原始情绪总是让我非常着迷，因为我们，我们已经从那些只被生存和本能统治和驱动的生物进化了太多。我们不再在荒野中狩猎或与邻近的部落战斗。也许在某些意义上我们仍然如此，但我们的社会确实已经进化到确保我们都温文尔雅、得体端庄，我们一直在压抑这些非常原始的情绪，然而它们依然存在。
They haven't dissolved or disappeared with increased sophistication. society is just asking us to hide it. So the main theory is that anger comes from primarily feeling threatened, feeling powerless, or that there is some part of who you are, what you stand for that has been trespassed. So this article published in 2017 called anger as a basic emotion and its role in personality, it describes it really well. Our anger serves as an internal sign that there is an obstacle or aversive situation that has crossed an emotional or physical boundary that we need to respond to. And our anger is one of the only emotions that is strong enough to get us to that point of acting. And this kind of relates to another dimension of anger,
They haven't dissolved or disappeared with increased sophistication. society is just asking us to hide it. So the main theory is that anger comes from primarily feeling threatened, feeling powerless, or that there is some part of who you are, what you stand for that has been trespassed. So this article published in 2017 called anger as a basic emotion and its role in personality, it describes it really well. Our anger serves as an internal sign that there is an obstacle or aversive situation that has crossed an emotional or physical boundary that we need to respond to. And our anger is one of the only emotions that is strong enough to get us to that point of acting. And this kind of relates to another dimension of anger,|||它们并没有随着成熟度的增加而溶解或消失。社会只是要求我们隐藏它。因此主要的理论是，愤怒主要来自于感到受到威胁、感到无力，或者你这个人、你所代表的某种立场被侵犯了。因此，2017年发表的一篇名为《愤怒作为一种基本情绪及其在人格中的作用》的文章对此进行了很好的描述。我们的愤怒作为一个内部信号，表明存在一个跨越了情感或身体边界的障碍或厌恶情况，我们需要对此做出反应。我们的愤怒是唯一足够强大到能让我们采取行动的情绪之一。这在某种程度上与愤怒的另一个维度有关，
which is that it can and is often a secondary emotion. Let me explain that a little bit further. our anger often masks a much more vulnerable feeling that we are not quite ready to confront yet. It masks our fear. It masks our hurt. It masks our disappointment. How powerless we feel. If you've ever been so angry that you've cried, you'll know that really well. That is the true emotion, the sadness, the disappointment really bubbling up. And sometimes anger is less complicated than the emotion that we really want to express. It's less complicated. It's less complicated. in the situation we're in, and so we hide behind our rage. Our anger is what makes us act when fear or sadness or disappointment can't. And as it wears off, it reveals what is truly at the
which is that it can and is often a secondary emotion. Let me explain that a little bit further. our anger often masks a much more vulnerable feeling that we are not quite ready to confront yet. It masks our fear. It masks our hurt. It masks our disappointment. How powerless we feel. If you've ever been so angry that you've cried, you'll know that really well. That is the true emotion, the sadness, the disappointment really bubbling up. And sometimes anger is less complicated than the emotion that we really want to express. It's less complicated. It's less complicated. in the situation we're in, and so we hide behind our rage. Our anger is what makes us act when fear or sadness or disappointment can't. And as it wears off, it reveals what is truly at the|||即它能够而且经常是一种次要情绪。让我进一步解释这一点。我们的愤怒通常掩盖了一种更加脆弱的感觉，而我们还没有准备好去面对这种感觉。它掩盖了我们的恐惧。它掩盖了我们的伤害。它掩盖了我们的失望。我们感到多么无力。如果你曾经愤怒到哭泣，你就会对这一点深有体会。那才是真正的、真正涌上心头的悲伤和失望。有时，愤怒比我们真正想要表达的情绪要简单得多。它不那么复杂。它不那么复杂。在我们所处的环境中，所以我们躲在愤怒背后。当恐惧、悲伤或失望无法让我们采取行动时，是我们的愤怒让我们行动起来。当它消退时，它揭示了真正处于
root of that wrath, that we are actually just really fragile, gentle creatures who have been hurt. Maybe you are not angry as a person. Maybe you just have a really delicate soul that's been crossed a few too many times and you've reverted to what feels easier. And when we see anger in any form, regardless of its origin, psychologists can kind of broadly categorize it into three different types. Firstly, we have hasty and sudden anger. And this is really connected to like the impulse for self-preservation. So it occurs when we feel really trapped in a situation or like something has just pushed
root of that wrath, that we are actually just really fragile, gentle creatures who have been hurt. Maybe you are not angry as a person. Maybe you just have a really delicate soul that's been crossed a few too many times and you've reverted to what feels easier. And when we see anger in any form, regardless of its origin, psychologists can kind of broadly categorize it into three different types. Firstly, we have hasty and sudden anger. And this is really connected to like the impulse for self-preservation. So it occurs when we feel really trapped in a situation or like something has just pushed|||这种暴怒根源的东西，其实我们只是非常脆弱、温柔、受过伤的生物。也许你这个人本身并不爱生气。也许你只是有一个非常纤细的灵魂，被伤害得太多次了，以至于你退回到了感觉更容易接受的状态。当我们看到任何形式的愤怒时，无论其根源如何，心理学家都可以将其大致分类为三种不同的类型。首先，我们有仓促和突然的愤怒。这确实与自我保护的冲动有关。所以当我们在某种情况下感到真的被困住了，或者觉得有什么事情刚刚把我们
us to the point of explosion. It's very episodic in nature. It comes from these, like, brief, uncontrollable bursts. But it doesn't mean that it hasn't been building up for a while. Maybe this anger has been simmering, just waiting for the final catalyst. The, like, straw that breaks the camel's back. Then we have settled and deliberate anger. And this is a reaction to a deliberate harm from someone else,
us to the point of explosion. It's very episodic in nature. It comes from these, like, brief, uncontrollable bursts. But it doesn't mean that it hasn't been building up for a while. Maybe this anger has been simmering, just waiting for the final catalyst. The, like, straw that breaks the camel's back. Then we have settled and deliberate anger. And this is a reaction to a deliberate harm from someone else,|||逼到爆发的边缘时，它就会发生。它本质上是非常间歇性的。它来自这种简短的、无法控制的爆发。但这并不意味着它没有酝酿一段时间。也许这种愤怒一直在酝酿，只在等待最后的催化剂。也就是压死骆驼的最后一根稻草。然后是我们称之为沉淀和蓄意的愤怒。这是对来自他人的蓄意伤害的一种反应，
something that is perhaps long term. It's anger that simmers, that settles, anger that creates actions. that are less impulsive, like hasty anger and more calculated. And then finally, we have dispositional anger. I think we all know people that are just angrier than others. They have that, like, fiery gene. And this dispositional anger is related more to an innate character trait than to instincts or cognitions. This also brings me to a really important point.
something that is perhaps long term. It's anger that simmers, that settles, anger that creates actions. that are less impulsive, like hasty anger and more calculated. And then finally, we have dispositional anger. I think we all know people that are just angrier than others. They have that, like, fiery gene. And this dispositional anger is related more to an innate character trait than to instincts or cognitions. This also brings me to a really important point.|||这种伤害或许是长期的。这是一种酝酿的、沉淀的愤怒，是一种催生行动的愤怒。这些行动不像仓促的愤怒那样冲动，而是更有计划性。最后，我们有性格倾向性愤怒。我想我们都认识这样的人，他们就是比其他人更容易生气。他们身上有那种火爆的基因。这种性格倾向性愤怒更多地与先天性格特征有关，而不是本能或认知。这也带给我一个非常重要的观点。
Like I said, there are some people who are just angrier than others. And there is actually a disorder for this. called intermittent explosive disorder. And this is really related to our ability to control our impulses. When we are unable to do that, the behavior that we might exhibit is these repeated angry outbursts, our failure to control our aggressive impulses. And normally it's not something that we want to do.
Like I said, there are some people who are just angrier than others. And there is actually a disorder for this. called intermittent explosive disorder. And this is really related to our ability to control our impulses. When we are unable to do that, the behavior that we might exhibit is these repeated angry outbursts, our failure to control our aggressive impulses. And normally it's not something that we want to do.|||就像我说的，有些人就是比其他人更容易愤怒。其实针对这种情况有一种精神障碍。叫做间歇性爆发障碍。这确实与我们控制冲动能力有关。当我们无法做到这一点时，我们可能会表现出的行为就是这种反复的愤怒爆发，我们无法控制自己的攻击性冲动。通常这不是我们想要做的事情。
It just feels like this explosion that has come out of nowhere. And normally the reaction is also very much out of proportion to the event that sparked that rage. This is obviously an extreme. You know, it is like a diagnosable disorder. But I think it does go to show how anger is in one way an emotion. For others, it can become a personality trait. And then for others, it can be a disordered part of who they are and how they, how the
It just feels like this explosion that has come out of nowhere. And normally the reaction is also very much out of proportion to the event that sparked that rage. This is obviously an extreme. You know, it is like a diagnosable disorder. But I think it does go to show how anger is in one way an emotion. For others, it can become a personality trait. And then for others, it can be a disordered part of who they are and how they, how the|||这感觉就像是一场凭空而来的大爆炸。通常这种反应也与引发这种狂怒的事件极不相称。这显然是一个极端。你知道的，这就像是一种可诊断的精神障碍。但我认为这确实说明了愤怒在某种程度上是一种情绪。对其他人来说，它会变成一种性格特征。而对另一些人来说，它可能是他们是谁以及他们如何，如何看待
world sees and how they see the world. When we feel any of these types of anger, though, something really unique. happens in our brain. There are entire regions devoted to processing this feeling. And the reason that anger feels so fiery is because firstly, it's almost entirely automatic and out of our control. And secondly, it activates this part of our brain known as the amygdala, one of the oldest parts of our brain, perhaps the most primal. It's nestled deep in there, right in the middle of our limbic system. And it is what is responsible for some of our most instinctual feelings. The ones that are going to ensure that you survive.
world sees and how they see the world. When we feel any of these types of anger, though, something really unique. happens in our brain. There are entire regions devoted to processing this feeling. And the reason that anger feels so fiery is because firstly, it's almost entirely automatic and out of our control. And secondly, it activates this part of our brain known as the amygdala, one of the oldest parts of our brain, perhaps the most primal. It's nestled deep in there, right in the middle of our limbic system. And it is what is responsible for some of our most instinctual feelings. The ones that are going to ensure that you survive.|||世界以及他们如何看待世界的一个失调的部分。然而，当我们感受到任何这些类型的愤怒时，一件非常独特的事情会在我们的大脑中发生。有整个区域专门用来处理这种感觉。愤怒之所以让人感觉如此火爆，是因为首先，它几乎完全是自动的，超出了我们的控制。其次，它激活了我们大脑中被称为杏仁核的部分，这是我们大脑中最古老的部分之一，也许也是最原始的。它深深地嵌入其中，正好位于我们边缘系统的正中央。它负责我们一些最本能的感受。那些将确保你生存下来的感受。
And those big ones are fear and anger. Fear and anger. Our ability to detect danger and respond are intrinsically linked. Sometimes hard to distinguish. It almost feels like anger is fear in more of like a hidden form. Instead of wanting to show that we're scared, we show that we are like dangerous or we show that we are angry. I think what's definitely true is that when this part of the brain takes over,
And those big ones are fear and anger. Fear and anger. Our ability to detect danger and respond are intrinsically linked. Sometimes hard to distinguish. It almost feels like anger is fear in more of like a hidden form. Instead of wanting to show that we're scared, we show that we are like dangerous or we show that we are angry. I think what's definitely true is that when this part of the brain takes over,|||其中最重要的两个就是恐惧和愤怒。恐惧和愤怒。我们检测危险并做出反应的能力是内在联系在一起的。有时很难区分。几乎感觉愤怒是恐惧的一种更隐蔽的形式。与其表现出我们很害怕，不如表现得我们很危险，或者表现得很愤怒。我认为可以确定的是，当大脑的这一部分接管时，
the unconscious, rational part of us tends to switch off. Anger, as has been shown in a lot of research, causes a reduction in our cognitive abilities and basically our ability to accurately process external stimuli. We don't tend to think straight anymore. We face a bunch of distortions to our reasoning abilities. For example, like we might see something and overreact, or we might see something and attribute blame to someone else, when in fact it is not their fault.
the unconscious, rational part of us tends to switch off. Anger, as has been shown in a lot of research, causes a reduction in our cognitive abilities and basically our ability to accurately process external stimuli. We don't tend to think straight anymore. We face a bunch of distortions to our reasoning abilities. For example, like we might see something and overreact, or we might see something and attribute blame to someone else, when in fact it is not their fault.|||我们无意识的、理性的部分往往会关闭。正如许多研究所表明的那样，愤怒会导致我们的认知能力下降，基本上是我们准确处理外部刺激的能力下降。我们不再能清晰地思考了。我们的推理能力面临着一系列的扭曲。例如，我们可能会看到某事并过度反应，或者我们可能会看到某事并将责任归咎于他人，而事实上这并不是他们的错。
And I think this can create a feedback loop where, as our cognitions become more distorted, we're less able to see clearly. The more blame we place on others, the more angry that we feel. And I think it's at that point when we sometimes see people do things that they normally really wouldn't do that is not within their normal personality traits. It doesn't mean that they didn't do it. They are still accountable. But a lot of the time, they are acting from a point of blind rage.
And I think this can create a feedback loop where, as our cognitions become more distorted, we're less able to see clearly. The more blame we place on others, the more angry that we feel. And I think it's at that point when we sometimes see people do things that they normally really wouldn't do that is not within their normal personality traits. It doesn't mean that they didn't do it. They are still accountable. But a lot of the time, they are acting from a point of blind rage.|||我认为这会产生一个反馈循环：随着我们的认知变得更加扭曲，我们看清真相的能力就会减弱。我们将越多的责任归咎于他人，就会感到越愤怒。我认为正是在那种时候，我们有时会看到人们做出他们平时绝不会做的事情，这些事情不符合他们的正常性格特征。这并不意味着他们没有做过。他们仍然要承担责任。但在很多时候，他们是在盲目狂怒驱使下行事的。
And I think that brings me to my main point. We don't know what to do with our anger. We don't know how to process it, whether we should forgive, how to forgive whether we should lash out, who we should tell, how to get rid of this feeling, and so we suppress the emotion, we let it show up in less than ideal ways. It may also be because of how you have come to see anger in the past. You've come to see it as an emotion that we should avoid. This often can be attributed to maybe being raised by really angry parents
And I think that brings me to my main point. We don't know what to do with our anger. We don't know how to process it, whether we should forgive, how to forgive whether we should lash out, who we should tell, how to get rid of this feeling, and so we suppress the emotion, we let it show up in less than ideal ways. It may also be because of how you have come to see anger in the past. You've come to see it as an emotion that we should avoid. This often can be attributed to maybe being raised by really angry parents|||我想这把我带到了我的核心观点。我们不知道该如何处理我们的愤怒。我们不知道该如何消化它，我们是否应该原谅，如何原谅，我们是否应该发火，我们应该告诉谁，如何摆脱这种感觉，所以我们压抑这种情绪，我们让它以不太理想的方式显露出来。这可能也是因为你过去看待愤怒的方式。你把它看作是一种我们应该避免的情绪。这通常可以归因于可能是被非常愤怒的父母抚养长大，
or seeing anger from a previous partner, we can see in those moments how ugly it can be, especially when it has total control over someone. It may also be that as a child, you are not given permission to express emotions like anger or rage in a safe space. You were punished for being frustrated or rightfully angry, angry in response to your boundaries being crossed. you are not given access to your full emotional bandwidth. So anytime you feel anger now as an adult,
or seeing anger from a previous partner, we can see in those moments how ugly it can be, especially when it has total control over someone. It may also be that as a child, you are not given permission to express emotions like anger or rage in a safe space. You were punished for being frustrated or rightfully angry, angry in response to your boundaries being crossed. you are not given access to your full emotional bandwidth. So anytime you feel anger now as an adult,|||或者是看到了前任伴侣的愤怒，我们在那些时刻可以看到它是多么丑陋，尤其是当它对一个人具有完全的控制权时。这也可能是因为在你还是个孩子的时候，你没有被允许在一个安全的空间里表达愤怒或暴怒等情绪。你因为感到沮丧或理所当然的愤怒而受到惩罚，这种愤怒是对你的界限被侵犯做出的反应。你没有获得充分表达情感的权利。所以现在作为成年人，每当你感到愤怒时，
you associate it with the shame and the punishment you received as a child. Or we vow not to be like the person who has let anger control them in our past. We know how much it hurts. We know how much it harms those around us. We are told and we know that anger is bad and therefore to feel it would make us bad. And so we push it down. we begin to believe that to feel anger makes us purely an angry person and nothing more. When we fear any kind of emotional reaction, it naturally leads to avoidance, and that is what
you associate it with the shame and the punishment you received as a child. Or we vow not to be like the person who has let anger control them in our past. We know how much it hurts. We know how much it harms those around us. We are told and we know that anger is bad and therefore to feel it would make us bad. And so we push it down. we begin to believe that to feel anger makes us purely an angry person and nothing more. When we fear any kind of emotional reaction, it naturally leads to avoidance, and that is what|||你就会把它与你小时候受到的羞辱和惩罚联系起来。或者我们发誓不成为过去那个让愤怒控制自己的人。我们知道这有多痛。我们知道这会给周围的人带来多大的伤害。我们被告知并且我们知道愤怒是不好的，因此感受到它会让我们变得糟糕。所以我们把它压下去。我们开始相信，感受到愤怒会让我们纯粹变成一个充满愤怒的人，除此之外别无其他。当我们害怕任何形式的情绪反应时，这自然会导致逃避，这就是
causes us to suppress a feeling, treat it like it's somewhat diseased. However, our body can really only hold on to an emotion for so long, you know, eventually we run out of like cognitive resources and cognitive strength to hold it down. So we end up exploding. And the reason we end up exploding is often totally unrelated to the origin of our anger. This is what Freud called displacement. And displacement is part of our unconscious defense mechanisms in which we project and find a new object for our anger rather than the original cause. it is why you may be really angry at your roommates or really angry at your younger sibling but then you end up snapping at someone on the internet or you end up like picking a fight with your partner
causes us to suppress a feeling, treat it like it's somewhat diseased. However, our body can really only hold on to an emotion for so long, you know, eventually we run out of like cognitive resources and cognitive strength to hold it down. So we end up exploding. And the reason we end up exploding is often totally unrelated to the origin of our anger. This is what Freud called displacement. And displacement is part of our unconscious defense mechanisms in which we project and find a new object for our anger rather than the original cause. it is why you may be really angry at your roommates or really angry at your younger sibling but then you end up snapping at someone on the internet or you end up like picking a fight with your partner|||导致我们压抑一种感觉的原因，把它当成某种有病的东西来对待。然而，我们的身体实际上只能维持一种情绪那么久，你知道的，最终我们会耗尽认知资源和认知力量来压制它。所以我们最终会爆发。而我们最终爆发的原因通常与我们愤怒的根源完全无关。这就是弗洛伊德所谓的置换。置换是我们无意识防御机制的一部分，在这种机制中，我们将愤怒投射并寻找一个新的对象，而不是最初的原因。这就是为什么你可能对你的室友非常生气，或者对你的弟弟妹妹非常生气，但最终却对互联网上的某个人恶语相加，或者最终和你的伴侣吵架。
this is just your body trying to find a way to let out your anger in an environment that it seems you know it sees as more appropriate and really what it comes from is originally like shame it comes from shame at your anger It comes from conflict aversion. It comes from not being able to put it in a place where it's going to do good. And I think at that point it's really useful to remember that like any emotion, anger is really just here to tell you something. It is just the messenger. It is trying to communicate with you that there is something in your life, an important emotional issue, a sense of dissatisfaction, something that is bothering you, a sense of dissatisfaction, something that is bothering you, a sense.
this is just your body trying to find a way to let out your anger in an environment that it seems you know it sees as more appropriate and really what it comes from is originally like shame it comes from shame at your anger It comes from conflict aversion. It comes from not being able to put it in a place where it's going to do good. And I think at that point it's really useful to remember that like any emotion, anger is really just here to tell you something. It is just the messenger. It is trying to communicate with you that there is something in your life, an important emotional issue, a sense of dissatisfaction, something that is bothering you, a sense of dissatisfaction, something that is bothering you, a sense.|||这只是你的身体试图在它认为更合适的环境中寻找一种宣泄愤怒的方式，而实际上这最初来自于像羞耻感一样的东西，它来自于对你愤怒的羞耻感。它来自于冲突厌恶。它来自于无法把它放在一个能发挥积极作用的地方。我认为在那种情况下，记住这一点非常有用：就像任何情绪一样，愤怒其实只是来告诉你一些事情。它只是信使。它试图与你沟通，表明你的生活中有些事情，一个重要的情感问题，一种不满感，有什么事情在困扰你，一种不满感，有什么事情在困扰你，一种感觉。
sense of injustice that is going against your values, that is going against your desires, your ambitions. It has been compromised. And if we were to ignore anger or kind of like try and opt out of it, what we would actually be ignoring is a lot of important information. And it would mean that we would never be able to stand up for ourselves if our boundary would be crossed, because we could never allow ourselves to feel wronged. Otherwise, that would be allowing ourselves to feel angry. Hopefully that kind of makes sense, right? I think about this a lot in terms of people who are in situations or if you're in a really fraught relationship and you just don't let yourself bring up the things that have bothered you. And you suppress it because to feel angry might
sense of injustice that is going against your values, that is going against your desires, your ambitions. It has been compromised. And if we were to ignore anger or kind of like try and opt out of it, what we would actually be ignoring is a lot of important information. And it would mean that we would never be able to stand up for ourselves if our boundary would be crossed, because we could never allow ourselves to feel wronged. Otherwise, that would be allowing ourselves to feel angry. Hopefully that kind of makes sense, right? I think about this a lot in terms of people who are in situations or if you're in a really fraught relationship and you just don't let yourself bring up the things that have bothered you. And you suppress it because to feel angry might|||这种不公正感违背了你的价值观，违背了你的愿望和雄心壮志。它受到了损害。如果我们忽视愤怒，或者试图回避它，我们实际上是在忽视大量重要信息。这意味着如果我们的界限被跨越，我们将永远无法挺身而出捍卫自己，因为我们永远不会允许自己感到委屈。否则，这就等于允许自己感到愤怒。希望这说得通，对吧？我经常这样思考那些处于某种处境中的人，或者如果你处于一段非常紧张的关系中，你就是不让自己提起那些困扰你的事情。你压抑它，因为感到愤怒可能会
compromise that relationship. You don't want to be angry in front of this person. Here's the thing, though, eventually that is going to boil over. It is going to get to the point where you cannot tolerate that for much longer. And that is why anger is so crucial, because it is a really valuable motivator for change. If we channel that initial impulse for violence and rage correctly, we can actually really unlock a lot of movement in our life. We can unlock a lot of creativity. I know this really, really well.
compromise that relationship. You don't want to be angry in front of this person. Here's the thing, though, eventually that is going to boil over. It is going to get to the point where you cannot tolerate that for much longer. And that is why anger is so crucial, because it is a really valuable motivator for change. If we channel that initial impulse for violence and rage correctly, we can actually really unlock a lot of movement in our life. We can unlock a lot of creativity. I know this really, really well.|||危及这段关系。你不想在这个人面前表现出愤怒。然而事实是，最终这种情况会彻底爆发。它会发展到你再也无法忍受的地步。这就是为什么愤怒如此关键，因为它是推动变革的宝贵动力。如果我们能正确引导最初的暴力和愤怒冲动，我们实际上真的可以释放我们生活中的许多活力。我们可以释放大量的创造力。我对此深有体会。
You can displace it. That's your first option. You can let it take over your entire life and you can let it make you violent and rageful. Or you can treat it like energy. Why do you want to divert that energy? In what parts of your life might it be useful to have access to that level of passion? Don't you want to kind of almost really tap into its power rather than wasting it on like a momentary explosion? you know, I think the best analogy I've heard about this topic is from this TED talk called anger is your ally. And the speaker explains that anger is very much like a child. You shouldn't let it drive the car that is going to be a terrible problem, but you also shouldn't stuff it in the trunk either. You need to treat anger like it's a passenger in the vehicle. You know, you know it's there. It's just cruising along with you. You're not trying to hide from it. But it's also not
You can displace it. That's your first option. You can let it take over your entire life and you can let it make you violent and rageful. Or you can treat it like energy. Why do you want to divert that energy? In what parts of your life might it be useful to have access to that level of passion? Don't you want to kind of really tap into its power rather than wasting it on like a momentary explosion? you know, I think the best analogy I've heard about this topic is from this TED talk called anger is your ally. And the speaker explains that anger is very much like a child. You shouldn't let it drive the car that is going to be a terrible problem, but you also shouldn't stuff it in the trunk either. You need to treat anger like it's a passenger in the vehicle. You know, you know it's there. It's just cruising along with you. You're not trying to hide from it. But it's also not|||你可以置换它。这是你的第一个选择。你可以让它接管你的整个生活，你可以让它让你变得暴力和狂怒. 或者你可以把它当成能量。你为什么要转移这种能量？在你生活的哪些部分，获得那种程度的热情可能会有用？难道你不想真正开发它的力量，而不是把它浪费在类似瞬间的爆发上吗？你知道的，关于这个话题我听过最好的类比来自于一个名为《愤怒是你的盟友》的TED演讲。演讲者解释说，愤怒非常像一个孩子。你不应该让他开车，那会是个可怕的问题，但你也不应该把他塞进后备箱。你需要把愤怒当作车里的乘客。你知道的，你知道他在那儿。他只是在和你一起巡航。你不是在试图躲避他。但他也
the front seat. I think this acceptance of our anger is not to justify holding onto it by no means. I think we often make the mistake in believing that raging and seething in silence is somehow going to hurt the person we're actually furious at or that it's productive. When actually, when we really like hold on to this rage and we hold on to this like aggressive instinct in this hurt, we are the person that it does the most damage to. But is the answer to that? that we should forgive. Do we always have to be the bigger person to let go of our anger? I personally, I don't think so. I think forgiveness is a privilege and you can, you know, you can still understand the ways in which someone has hurt you, the way certain actions have
the front seat. I think this acceptance of our anger is not to justify holding onto it by no means. I think we often make the mistake in believing that raging and seething in silence is somehow going to hurt the person we're actually furious at or that it's productive. When actually, when we really like hold on to this rage and we hold on to this like aggressive instinct in this hurt, we are the person that it does the most damage to. But is the answer to that? that we should forgive. Do we always have to be the bigger person to let go of our anger? I personally, I don't think so. I think forgiveness is a privilege and you can, you know, you can still understand the ways in which someone has hurt you, the way certain actions have|||不是坐在前排。我认为这种对我们愤怒的接纳绝不是为抓住不放寻找借口。我认为我们经常犯这样一个错误：相信在沉默中暴怒和生闷气会以某种方式伤害到我们真正愤怒的人，或者这样做是富有成效的。而实际上，当我们真正抓住这种狂怒不放，抓住这种伤害中的攻击性本能不放时，受到伤害最大的人其实是我们自己。但这的答案是？我们应该原谅吗？为了释放愤怒，我们难道非得表现得大度一些吗？我个人并不这么认为。我认为原谅是一种特权，你可以，你知道的，你仍然可以理解某人伤害你的方式，某些行为方式
gone against your values and not need to subsequently hurt that person as well to find release. You can find peace with your anger. And sometimes, I think we really celebrate forgiveness as this like really pure and good thing. You know, there's a lot of religious undertones to that and that it's going to make us so much lighter and such better people. But I also don't think that it's going to help us release our rage. I don't think that forgiveness is something that we should rush. I think that anger actually needs an outlet and it needs to be processed and it needs to be worked through. It needs to be treated with respect before we get to the point that we can be stoics about it. So in that moment,
gone against your values and not need to subsequently hurt that person as well to find release. You can find peace with your anger. And sometimes, I think we really celebrate forgiveness as this like really pure and good thing. You know, there's a lot of religious undertones to that and that it's going to make us so much lighter and such better people. But I also don't think that it's going to help us release our rage. I don't think that forgiveness is something that we should rush. I think that anger actually needs an outlet and it needs to be processed and it needs to be worked through. It needs to be treated with respect before we get to the point that we can be stoics about it. So in that moment,|||违背了你的价值观，并且不需要为了找到宣泄而随后也去伤害那个人。你可以与你的愤怒和平共处。有时，我认为我们确实把原谅奉为一件非常纯洁和美好的事情。你知道的，这其中有很多宗教色彩，认为它会让我们变得轻松得多，成为更好的人。但我也认为这无助于我们释放心中的狂怒。我认为原谅不应该是一件我们应该仓促行事的事情。我认为愤怒实际上需要一个宣泄口，需要被处理，需要被理清。在我们能够对它保持斯多葛式的平静之前，它需要得到尊重。所以在那个时刻，
you kind of have three options. You can channel your anger through sublimation. You can create something with it. You can use it as motivation. Find it, like find a positive way to process that feeling. You can adopt the stoic approach, which is, oh, I'm just going to let this emotion wash over me without needing to reach out and touch it. Or you can listen to the impulse. and you can explode. You can inevitably say things you don't mean, you can lash out, you can burn the fucking world down and that might feel great in the moment, but then you're kind of just left with the remains there. You're left with a lot of burnt bridges and there's not much more to make of it. So I think option one and two are our best bet, but sometimes it's hard to get there, especially
you kind of have three options. You can channel your anger through sublimation. You can create something with it. You can use it as motivation. Find it, like find a positive way to process that feeling. You can adopt the stoic approach, which is, oh, I'm just going to let this emotion wash over me without needing to reach out and touch it. Or you can listen to the impulse. and you can explode. You can inevitably say things you don't mean, you can lash out, you can burn the fucking world down and that might feel great in the moment, but then you're kind of just left with the remains there. You're left with a lot of burnt bridges and there's not much more to make of it. So I think option one and two are our best bet, but sometimes it's hard to get there, especially|||你大致有三个选择。你可以通过升华来引导你的愤怒。你可以用它来创造一些东西。你可以把它当作动力。找到它，比如找到一种积极的方式来处理这种感觉。你可以采取斯多葛学派的方法，也就是，哦，我只是让这种情绪从我身上冲刷而过，而不需要伸手去触碰它。或者你可以听从冲动。然后你就会爆发。你不可避免地会说出违心的话，你会大发雷霆，你会把这该死的世界烧成灰烬，这在当时可能感觉很棒，但之后你大概只能留在那里面对残骸了。你留下了许多烧毁的桥梁，对此也无能为力了。所以我认为第一和第二个选项是我们的最佳选择，但有时很难做到这一点，尤其是
when anger has really ruled you unconsciously for so long. So what I want to talk about next is how we can honor the emotion whilst also letting it serve us. So all of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
when anger has really ruled you unconsciously for so long. So what I want to talk about next is how we can honor the emotion whilst also letting it serve us. So all of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.|||当愤怒在不知不觉中长期统治你的时候。所以我接下来要谈的是，我们如何既能尊重这种情绪，又能让它为我们服务。所有这些以及更多内容，将在短暂休息后继续。2%. 这就是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中。我剖析了我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。
I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-P-Sent on the I-Hart Radio.
I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-P-Sent on the I-Hart Radio.|||我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾相信种子油天生具有炎症性。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是 I-Hart 电台上的 T-W-O-P-P-Sent。
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man.
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man.|||Apple Podcasts，或在你获取播客的任何地方。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，千万不要惹乡下女孩。玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也千万别惹她的朋友。我们总是说要相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在这新一季的《闺蜜》中……天哪，这就是同一个人。
A group of women discover they have... all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target.
A group of women discover they have... all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target.|||一群女人发现她们……都和一个高产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像是被卡车撞了。我想，怎么会发生这种事？警察似乎并不在意。于是她们决定自己动手。我说，噢，见鬼去吧。我发誓。我将是他最后一个目标。
He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Remember when Diana Ross double-tap little Kim's boobs at the VIA, man's or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little camp?
He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Remember when Diana Ross double-tap little Kim's boobs at the VIA, man's or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little camp?|||他会得到他应得的下场。收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。在 Iheart radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but yeah, yeah, literally. But just so you know.
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but yeah, yeah, literally. But just so you know.|||好吧，你可以在《回顾往昔》(Look Back at It) 播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格lish。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。其中包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对谈，滔滔不绝地讲述20世纪80年代的快克。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我可以整天都在谈论快克，但是是的，是的，真的。但只是让你知道。
I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed correct. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed correct. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.|||我的意思是，在这一点上，这是我们第二次讨论快克了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的线索。现在我们还把艾滋病摆上了台面。谢谢你把那句话说完。是的。我认为没有比这更重要的黑人年份了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast. Learn the Hardway with me, your host. and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast. Learn the Hardway with me, your host. and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience|||对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在 IHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客。《吃一堑长一智》，我是你们的主持人。也是你最喜欢的心理治疗师，凯尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将带来我十多年来的个人经验，
in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough.
in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough.|||在心理健康领域的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，却还在继续追逐，并且不知道什么时候我们已经做得够多了。
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.|||因为人们盯着记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在人间做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两个不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。这也是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正成为一个好人。
Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. So the two ways we've mentioned for dealing with anger so far is by processing and channeling rather than letting it rule you. And I want to talk through some specific tips for doing so. Firstly, once again, I want to clarify. Anger is not an emotion to be avoided by any means. It is good that you feel angry sometimes. It shows that you have boundaries. It shows that you have a sense of injustice. It shows that you are protective of yourself. And I actually think that you're
Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. So the two ways we've mentioned for dealing with anger so far is by processing and channeling rather than letting it rule you. And I want to talk through some specific tips for doing so. Firstly, once again, I want to clarify. Anger is not an emotion to be avoided by any means. It is good that you feel angry sometimes. It shows that you have boundaries. It shows that you have a sense of injustice. It shows that you are protective of yourself. And I actually think that you're|||加入我和凯尔·盖恩斯 (Kear Gaines) 的行列，在我的新播客《吃一堑长一智》(Learn the Hard Way) 中，就治愈、成长、为人父、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的 I Heart Radio 应用。搜索“Learn the Hardway”并立即收听。所以我们迄今为止提到的处理愤怒的两种方法是：通过加工和引导，而不是让它统治你。我想讨论一些这样做的具体技巧。首先，我想再次澄清。愤怒绝不是一种应该被避免的情绪。你有时感到愤怒是件好事。这表明你有底线。这表明你有正义感。这表明你在保护自己。事实上我认为你
think that's really, really important. I also think when we ignore anger, when we suppress it, obviously we can explode, yada, yada, yada, but it also maybe indicates that somewhere along the way you were taught that to experience and show all your emotions was shameful. And I think that the shame around emotions is one of those kind of generational patterns and things that we are taught by our parents that we need to unlearn. So here's a lot of. So here's a lot of. So here's a how we're going to go about it instead. Firstly, when you were feeling this rage, for any reason, avoid what we like to call the catharsis myth. So a catharsis is this thing that provides release. It is this like huge explosion of energy that like makes us feel a lot better. When we talk about
think that's really, really important. I also think when we ignore anger, when we suppress it, obviously we can explode, yada, yada, yada, but it also maybe indicates that somewhere along the way you were taught that to experience and show all your emotions was shameful. And I think that the shame around emotions is one of those kind of generational patterns and things that we are taught by our parents that we need to unlearn. So here's a lot of. So here's a lot of. So here's a how we're going to go about it instead. Firstly, when you were feeling this rage, for any reason, avoid what we like to call the catharsis myth. So a catharsis is this thing that provides release. It is this like huge explosion of energy that like makes us feel a lot better. When we talk about|||认为这非常非常重要。我还认为，当我们忽视愤怒，当我们压抑它时，显然我们会爆发，等等等等，但这或许也表明，在过去的某个时候，有人教导你，体验和展示你的所有情绪是件羞耻的事。我认为围绕情绪的羞耻感是那种代代相传的模式之一，是我们从父母那里学到需要戒除的东西。所以这里有很多。所以这里有很多。所以接下来我们要这样处理。首先，当你由于任何原因感到这种狂怒时，避免我们所谓的宣泄迷思。宣泄就是那种提供释放的事情。它是那种巨大的能量爆发，让我们感觉好多了。当我们谈论
anger, a lot of people talk about venting, talk about ranting as a way to kind of like release their anger effectively. They think about it as like turning the tap on and just like letting out some of the pressure. But a psychologist that I was reading into about this put it very well, when you vent your anger or blow off steam, when you are screaming, when you're like really mad, when you're just having this like huge vent to your friend, it actually keeps our arousal levels really high. Have you ever like had a moment where someone has done something? that has made you so angry.
anger, a lot of people talk about venting, talk about ranting as a way to kind of like release their anger effectively. They think about it as like turning the tap on and just like letting out some of the pressure. But a psychologist that I was reading into about this put it well, when you vent your anger or blow off steam, when you are screaming, when you're like really mad, when you're just having this like huge vent to your friend, it actually keeps our arousal levels really high. Have you ever like had a moment where someone has done something? that has made you so angry.|||愤怒时，很多人谈论宣泄，谈论大发雷霆，以此作为有效释放愤怒的一种方式。他们认为这就像打开水龙头，把一些压力释放出来。但我读到的一位关于此事的心理学家说得很好，当你宣泄愤怒或发泄情绪时，当你尖叫时，当你真的很生时，当你只是向朋友大量宣泄时，这实际上会让我们的觉醒水平保持在很高的高度。你有没有过这样的时候，有人做了一件什么事？让你如此愤怒。
And you've walked away from it. You've kind of thought about it. And then a few days later, your friend's like, hey, remember when that person did that thing? And it just makes you feel angry afterwards when you talk about it with them. You think that it's going to make you feel better. I actually don't think it really does.
And you've walked away from it. You've kind of thought about it. And then a few days later, your friend's like, hey, remember when that person did that thing? And it just makes you feel angry afterwards when you talk about it with them. You think that it's going to make you feel better. I actually don't think it really does.|||而你已经走开了。你一直在思考这件事。然后几天后，你的朋友说，嘿，还记得那个人做过的那件事吗？当你和他们谈论这件事时，只会让你事后感到愤怒。你以为这会让你感觉好点。我其实觉得它并没有。
It's like using gasoline to put out of fire. It just doesn't work. And I know that that advice feels counterintuitive because we feel like when we're venting, when we're ranting, that we're doing something about this feeling and therefore that we're processing it. However, I think there are more sustainable ways of going about it that don't keep us in such a state of like active anger. Like there's ways that we can exhaust the feeling is probably a better way of putting it rather than continuing to exacerbate it or accelerating it. So
It's like using gasoline to put out of fire. It just doesn't work. And I know that that advice feels counterintuitive because we feel like when we're venting, when we're ranting, that we're doing something about this feeling and therefore that we're processing it. However, I think there are more sustainable ways of going about it that don't keep us in such a state of like active anger. Like there's ways that we can exhaust the feeling is probably a better way of putting it rather than continuing to exacerbate it or accelerating it. So|||这就像用汽油灭火。根本不管用。我知道这个建议感觉有违直觉，因为我们觉得当我们宣泄时，当我们大发雷霆时，我们正在对这种感觉采取行动，因此我们正在处理它。然而，我认为有更具可持续性的方法，不会让我们陷入这种积极愤怒的状态。比如有些方法可以让我们耗尽这种感觉，这或许是一个更好的说法，而不是继续加剧它或加速它。所以
exercise is great, particularly something. cardio-focused, but I've also found boxing incredibly useful. I think that although it can still increase arousal in the moment, it also exhausts me afterwards and, you know, therapy is great and all, but something really does have to be said about just hitting a bag for an hour and leaving, being like super sweaty and just feeling like this, all of this like emotion and feeling that was buzzing in your body has a place to land. There's also this technique. I'm have for processing, rage, and actually a bunch of emotions. And I call it crazy dance. And I've talked about this before on the show. And it's what it sounds like. I want you to just put on your
exercise is great, particularly something. cardio-focused, but I've also found boxing incredibly useful. I think that although it can still increase arousal in the moment, it also exhausts me afterwards and, you-know, therapy is great and all, but something really does have to be said about just hitting a bag for an hour and leaving, being like super sweaty and just feeling like this, all of this like emotion and feeling that was buzzing in your body has a place to land. There's also this technique. I'm have for processing, rage, and actually a bunch of emotions. And I call it crazy dance. And I've talked about this before on the show. And it's what it sounds like. I want you to just put on your|||锻炼很棒，尤其是以有氧运动为主的运动，但我还发现拳击非常有用。我认为尽管它在当下仍然会增加觉醒水平，但它事后也会让我精疲力竭，你知道的，心理治疗很棒之类的话，但不得不说，击打沙袋一个小时然后离开，浑身大汗淋漓，感觉身体里所有嗡嗡作响的情绪和感觉都有了着落，这种感觉确实不同凡响。还有这种技巧。我用来处理狂怒，实际上是一堆情绪的技巧。我称之为疯狂舞蹈。我在节目中以前也谈到过这个。它正如听起来的那样。我希望你戴上
headphones and just go absolutely wild. Let loose. I don't want it to look good. I don't want it to be a cool dance. I want it to be the most energetic, crazy dance. You can think of legs moving, arms moving, body twisting. This acts as a form of somatic therapy, where we are able to release damaging pent-up emotions using our bodies. And that is the place where they're often stored, right? So I want you before and after to notice how your body feels and then where you've been holding stress, maybe you have like muscle tension or pain. And afterwards, I want you to notice whether those parts have experienced a sense of relief,
headphones and just go absolutely wild. Let loose. I don't want it to look good. I don't want it to be a cool dance. I want it to be the most energetic, crazy dance. You can think of legs moving, arms moving, body twisting. This acts as a form of somatic therapy, where we are able to release damaging pent-up emotions using our bodies. And that is the place where they're often stored, right? So I want you before and after to notice how your body feels and then where you've been holding stress, maybe you have like muscle tension or pain. And afterwards, I want you to notice whether those parts have experienced a sense of relief,|||耳机，然后彻底疯狂。尽情释放。我不在乎它好不好看。我不需要它是一支酷炫的舞蹈。我希望它是最具活力、最疯狂的舞蹈。你能想象到的双腿移动、双臂挥舞、身体扭动。这起到了躯体疗法的作用，我们可以利用身体释放具有破坏性的压抑情绪。而那通常正是它们储存的地方，对吧？所以我希望你在开始前和结束后注意一下你的身体感觉，然后注意你把压力藏在了哪里，也许你有肌肉紧绷或疼痛。结束后，我希望你注意这些部位是否感到了缓解，
whether there has been some kind of release in those muscles, in those parts of your body. I think it works in so many situations. Another way to go about it is make sure that before you address your anger, you calm your body by giving it enough oxygen. If you think about it, when we're really, really frustrated and upset, our breathing gets a lot deeper, a lot faster, sorry, a lot faster. And when it's really fast, like this, you're not taking in that much oxygen. When our brain is low on oxygen, our thinking becomes a little bit more like disturbed. It becomes a lot slower. And breathing exercises are a way to firstly help us calm down, but also get that oxygen back into our brain to make a smart, informed decision.
whether there has been some kind of release in those muscles, in those parts of your body. I think it works in so many situations. Another way to go about it is make sure that before you address your anger, you calm your body by giving it enough oxygen. If you think about it, when we're really, really frustrated and upset, our breathing gets a lot deeper, a lot faster, sorry, a lot faster. And when it's really fast, like this, you're not taking in that much oxygen. When our brain is low on oxygen, our thinking becomes a little bit more like disturbed. It becomes a lot slower. And breathing exercises are a way to firstly help us calm down, but also get that oxygen back into our brain to make a smart, informed decision.|||这些肌肉、你身体的那些部位是否得到了某种释放。我认为它在很多情况下都管用。另一种方法是确保在处理愤怒之前，通过为身体提供充足的氧气来让身体平静下来。如果你仔细想想，当我们非常非常沮丧和心烦意乱时，我们的呼吸会变得更深、更快，抱歉，快得多。当它非常快，像这样时，你并没有吸入多少氧气。当我们的大脑缺氧时，我们的思考就会变得有点像受到干扰。它会慢得多。而呼吸练习一方面可以帮助我们平静下来，另一方面也可以把氧气重新输送回我们的大脑，以便做出明智的、知情的决定。
I know we hear a lot about breathing exercises in therapy and in psychology. And if you go to therapy, it's like one of those staples in a therapist toolkit. That and like meditation and mindfulness. And sometimes when we hear about those things too much, we discredit it. We think it doesn't work, but it does. The science says that it does, and it really helps in these situations. So deliberately practicing, like, a relaxed breathing pattern. So breathing in for eight, holding for four, breathing out for eight.
I know we hear a lot about breathing exercises in therapy and in psychology. And if you go to therapy, it's like one of those staples in a therapist toolkit. That and like meditation and mindfulness. And sometimes when we hear about those things too much, we discredit it. We think it doesn't work, but it does. The science says that it does, and it really helps in these situations. So deliberately practicing, like, a relaxed breathing pattern. So breathing in for eight, holding for four, breathing out for eight.|||我知道我们在心理治疗和心理学中经常听到关于呼吸练习的内容。如果你去做心理治疗，这就像是治疗师工具箱中的必备工具之一。还有冥想和正念。有时当我们听到这些事情太多时，我们就会产生怀疑。我们认为它不管用，但它确实管用。科学表明它确实管用，并且在这些情况下真的很有帮助。所以要刻意练习，比如，一种放松的呼吸模式。吸气八秒，屏住呼吸四秒，呼气八秒。
It brings a lot of our involuntary functions like our breathing under control. And it shows us that other things we think are out of our control, like anger, are actually something that we have a say over, that we can almost operate and move and have some decision making over. So control breathing really can cause quite profound physiological changes. It lowers our blood pressure. It lowers our heart rate. It reduces stress levels and levels of stress hormones in the blood. So all of which I think is a really good start to processing anger in whatever form you choose to. My favorite form, though, is through creative channeling. So creative channeling is where you take your anger and you make something with it. It helps us place our anger, express our anger,
It brings a lot of our involuntary functions like our breathing under control. And it shows us that other things we think are out of our control, like anger, are actually something that we have a say over, that we can almost operate and move and have some decision making over. So control breathing really can cause quite profound physiological changes. It lowers our blood pressure. It lowers our heart rate. It reduces stress levels and levels of stress hormones in the blood. So all of which I think is a really good start to processing anger in whatever form you choose to. My favorite form, though, is through creative channeling. So creative channeling is where you take your anger and you make something with it. It helps us place our anger, express our anger,|||它使我们的许多自主功能（如呼吸）受到控制。它向我们表明，其他我们认为超出我们控制的事情，比如愤怒，实际上是我们有发言权的事情，我们几乎可以对其进行操作、移动并行使一些决策权。因此，控制呼吸确实能引起相当深刻的生理变化。它能降低我们的血压。它能降低我们的心率。它能降低压力水平以及血液中应激激素的水平。所以我认为，无论你选择何种形式，这都是处理愤怒的一个非常好的开始。不过我最喜欢的形式是通过创造性的引导。所以创造性的引导就是你带着愤怒，用它来创造一些东西。它帮助我们安置愤怒，表达愤怒，
and make it tangible. It takes us, you know, takes that emotion out of our mind and onto the page. Like if we're making a piece of art or a sculpture or anything of the sort, it really allows us to see this emotion is something that isn't just held up in our brain, but has a place in the world, a recognizable place outside of our body. Additionally, I think when we're like partaking in something creative, it helps us enter into a flow state. A flow state is this kind of state of mind where we aren't so much focused on what's bothering us, just the task at hand. We feel really fulfilled by it. We feel really excited by it, challenged by it, but also just extremely focused. And it actually is amazing because whilst you're in a flow state, it's really hard to think about
并将其具象化。它把我们的情绪从脑海中带到纸面上。就像我们制作一件艺术品、一个雕塑或任何类似的东西一样，它真的能让我们看到这种情绪不仅仅是停留在我们的脑海里，而是在世界上有一个位置，一个在我们身体之外清晰可见的位置。此外，我认为当我们参与创造性活动时，它有助于我们进入心流状态。心流状态是一种心态，在这种状态下，我们不再那么关注那些困扰我们的事情，而只专注于手头的任务。我们从中感到真正的满足。我们对它感到兴奋、充满挑战，同时也极其专注。事实上，这太神奇了，因为当你处于心流状态时，你很难去思考
more than one thing. And so you come back from practicing this creative exercise from making something with not only a fresh set of eyes, but with kind of like a renewed sense of peace and a renewed sense of calm. This mainly focuses on how you can manage your anger on an individual level, but obviously someone has given us a reason to feel angry. And I'm not just not saying that in a way of like, that we should be endorsing blame, but anger is often environmental, something has triggered it. And so our reaction is also probably going to be environmental or external or interpersonal as well. Here are some tips for managing that, because we know anger does a lot of damage when we don't have control over it. It causes us to just do so many things that we wouldn't normally do,
超过一件事情。因此，当你完成这种创造性的练习、创造出一些东西回来时，不仅带着一双崭新的眼睛，而且带着一种焕然一新的平和感和镇定感。这主要集中在你如何在一个人的层面上管理你的愤怒，但显然有人给了我们生气的理由。我这样说并不是在纵容指责，但愤怒往往是环境造成的，有什么东西触发了它。所以我们的反应也可能是环境的、外部的或人际的。以下是一些管理愤怒的技巧，因为我们知道，当我们无法控制愤怒时，它会造成极大的破坏。它会导致我们做出许多平时不会做的事情，
often at the expense of the people that are closest to us. They are the closest to the epicenter, they get the most kind of heat from this feeling. So when you are processing your anger, when you feel rage, avoid projecting, avoid displacing, as Freud would say, I think you need to acknowledge when you have allowed someone else to be the target of your anger when they are not the source. For example, you've come home from like a really rough day at work where people have just been super rude and you just snap at your partner. And it's not fair because, and it's probably not fair to snap at anyone really, but it's definitely not fair to snap at this person who probably doesn't know what's going on and is just wanting to make you happy and just wanting to see you happy as well.
往往以牺牲我们最亲近的人为代价。他们距离风暴中心最近，承受了这种情绪带来的最多热度。因此，当你处理自己的愤怒、感到狂怒时，要避免投射，避免置换，正如弗洛伊德所说的那样，我认为你需要承认，当别人并不是愤怒的根源时，你却让他们成为了你愤怒的目标。例如，你从工作压力极大的日子里回到家，那里的人对你非常粗鲁，然后你突然对伴侣发脾气。这很不公平，因为，对任何人发脾气大概都不公平，但对这个可能不知道发生了什么、只想让你开心、只想看到你快乐的人发脾气，绝对是不公平的。
And I think it's easy to project onto those people because we know that we kind of know that they're going to take it in a way, the way that we can't snap at a stranger. But once again, they're not deserving. And it will do harm to your relationship. So in those moments, recognize it, apologize to that person and explain why. talk about why it is that you came into an argument, that you came into a situation or a room or an interaction feeling that rage. And make sure they know what part of it may have been because of them
而且我认为很容易把情绪投射到这些人身上，因为我们知道，某种程度上我们知道他们会包容，而这是我们对陌生人时做不到的。但话又说回来，他们并不罪有应得。这会损害你们的关系。所以在那些时刻，要认清这一点，向那个人道歉并解释原因。谈谈为什么你会带着那种愤怒进入一场争论、一种情况、一个房间或一次互动。并确保让他们知道其中有多少部分可能是因为他们，
or what part of it really wasn't to do with them. So that they're not sitting there waiting for you to just blow up, that they're not having an anxious reaction to your feelings of rage. There's a strategy used in anger management called the, 30-30 intervention that I think is a really good and useful strategy for those moments when you do displace your anger onto someone who doesn't deserve it or when you've just had a really rough day and you know that this this like passion and this feeling is really building up so take 30 seconds to remove yourself from a situation that may be frustrating you 30 seconds to do
或者有多少部分真的与他们无关。这样他们就不会坐在那里等着你爆发，他们就不会对你的愤怒情绪产生焦虑的反应。愤怒管理中有一种策略叫做30-30干预法，我认为对于那些将愤怒转移到不该承受的人身上，或者当你度过了糟糕的一天、知道这种激情和情绪正在真正积聚的时刻，这是一个非常好且有用的策略。所以，花30秒时间让自己离开那个可能让你沮丧的环境，花30秒时间做
something else particularly something with your hands because it shows our brain that we're doing something about this problem, this problem emotion that we're having, or something physical to release that bodily tension, and then 30 seconds to create a coping strategy. Maybe that coping strategy would be, all right, I need a few more minutes to go on a walk, or I'm going to write down exactly why I'm upset, I'm going to journal about this, and then I'm going to come back to this person and we can talk about it. I also say all the time, let people make mistakes. Don't let other people always be the source of your anger because they don't meet your expectations and because you are lowering your threshold for their behavior. I'm going to explain that
其他事情，尤其是用手做的事情，因为这向我们的大脑表明，我们正在针对这个问题、我们正在经历的问题情绪做些什么，或者做些体力活动来释放身体的紧张，然后花30秒制定应对策略。也许应对策略会是：好吧，我需要多花几分钟去散步，或者我要写下我沮丧的具体原因，我要写日记记录这件事，然后我会回来找这个人，我们可以谈谈。我一直都在说，允许别人犯错。不要总是让别人成为你生气的根源，因为他们没有达到你的期望，因为你降低了对他们行为的标准。我要解释一下
a little bit more, but sometimes I think we become angry because we have false expectations about other people and when they don't meet them, we blame them rather than blaming ourselves for not being honest about what we can expect from someone. The same way that you're allowed to make mistakes, and be your own person, these people are allowed that as well. And I think that our angus comes from a sense of like reality, the reality we want, not matching up with kind of what is actually going to happen. And sometimes that's fair to be angry about, right? Like the reality is you've expect everyone around you to be really, really nice and kind and someone isn't, that makes you angry. But if the reality is, oh, I expect my partner to have done like every single chore in the
这一点，但有时我认为我们生气是因为我们对别人抱有错误的期望，当他们没有达到期望时，我们责怪他们，而不是责怪自己没有对可以对某人抱有什么期望保持诚实。就像你被允许犯错并做你自己一样，这些人也被允许这样做。我认为我们的愤怒来自于某种现实，我们想要的现实与实际会发生的事情不相符。有时为此感到生气是情有可原的，对吧？比如，现实是你期望周围的每个人都非常好、非常善良，而有人并非如此，这让你生气。但如果现实是，哦，我期望我的伴侣做完所有的家务，
household, even though he also works full time and you come back and he's just gotten home before you and he hasn't done that. And reality doesn't meet, you know, blah, blah, blah. I don't think it's fair in those times to be angry. Let other people make mistakes. And also, when you're really frustrated about something, when you really feel like something is so hard to let go of, you're so filled with rage that it's not going anywhere. Don't say you're over it when you're not. Don't pretend that you are fine. That is just another form of suppression. And it is going to come up later. I think a lot of the time we really want to be forgiving. And we want to pretend that the emotion just isn't there because it is so uncomfortable to feel. And we hear it all the time is someone is really
即使他也要全职工作，当你回来时，他刚比你到家一会儿，他还没有做那些事。现实不符合预期，等等等等。我认为在那些时刻生气是不公平的。允许别人犯错。而且，当你对某事感到非常沮丧，当你真的觉得有些事情很难放下、满腔怒火无处发泄时。当你还没放下时，不要说你已经放下了。不要假装你很好。那只是压抑的另一种形式。它迟早会爆发的。我想很多时候我们真的很想原谅。我们想假装这种情绪根本不存在，因为感受它太不舒服了。我们经常听到有人
upset by something and they go, it's fine, I'm fine. Like, let's move on. I don't want to talk about it. No, no, I'm over. I'm over. I forgive you. It's very easy to say those words as well if you're a people pleaser and if you feel like your anger is not justified. But this is your reminder that really take that closing of the feeling, that closing of the trigger, that closing of whatever has caused your anger. Make sure you take the closing of that chapter seriously. Don't close it too soon. Don't close it prematurely because it will bubble and it will fester and it will come up at the worst time. Finally, if there is a particular person, you are upset at. Practice both assertive communication. but also practice calm communication. Have you ever had those moments where you, like, you know that a friend is mad at you or you know that you've done something to upset someone and you go
对某事感到非常沮丧，然后他们说：“没关系，我很好。让我们继续吧。我不想谈这个。不，不，我放下了。我放下了。我原谅你。”如果你是个老好人，如果你觉得自己的愤怒是不正当的，说出这些话其实很容易。但这是对你的提醒：真正认真对待那种情绪的闭环、触发点的闭环、导致你生气的任何事情的闭环。确保你认真对待这一章的闭环。不要过早地结束它，不要操之过急，因为它会像气泡一样积聚，会溃烂，并在最糟糕的时候爆发。最后，如果你对某个人感到不满。既要实践自信的沟通，
into the conversation and you're just immediately defensive and you're immediately really upset and you're immediately angry or they're immediately angry. It is so hard to ever resolve something when we come to the table with this primal emotion at the forefront rather than like we said in the passenger seat. So think through your initial reaction, the first thing you want to do and then sleep on it. It will always feel better in the morning and maybe you will have thought again about burning the whole world down.
也要实践冷静的沟通。你有没有过这样的时刻：你知道一个朋友生你的气，或者你知道你做了什么事惹恼了别人，然后你
Take a step back from the first thing that you want to do in response to your anger and make sure you are, expressing what you need in an assertive yet calm way. I often find this difficult when people are like, oh my gosh, you're so angry. Like, you're overreacting. Like women especially, you're so emotional. You're allowed to have this feeling, right? I'm not saying that you need to be like calm about it for them. I'm saying you need to be calm about it for you. Calm about it for you because you're able to go in with a really clear way. of addressing what you need. A really clear way of trying, at least, to show them why you feel this way, why you feel like a boundary has been crossed, why you feel angry. I hate when people have
进入对话，立刻就开始防御，立刻就很沮丧，立刻就很生气，或者对方立刻就很生气。当我们把这种原始情绪放在最前面，而不是像我们刚才说的放在副驾驶座上时，要想解决任何问题都难如登天。所以，仔细想想你最初的反应，你最想做的事情，然后睡一觉再决定。第二天早上感觉总会好一些，也许你会重新考虑是不是要把整个世界都烧毁。
their reality kind of discredited because they are emotional when that is like literally the thing that we've been talking about this entire episode. This emotion is not shameful. It is not bad, but it is bad when you let it do things that hurt others deliberately, that hurt others without a second thought to it or that make it so you can't actually get what you need out of a situation. So I think it's really important here to have a healthy relationship with anger and how it is expressed to other people so that it can, I think, be a tool rather than an obstacle and that in other situations it can really help motivate change. It can help motivate progress towards a better understanding between you and someone else or a better out.
从你对愤怒的第一反应中退一步，确保你以自信而又冷静的方式表达你的需求。我经常发现，当人们说“天哪，你太生气了。你反应过度了。尤其是女人，你太情绪化了”时，这很困难。你有权拥有这种感觉，对吧？我并不是说你需要为了他们保持冷静。我是说你需要为了你自己保持冷静。为了你自己保持冷静，因为这样你才能以一种非常清晰的方式去解决你的需求。以一种非常清晰的方式，至少向他们展示为什么你会有这种感觉，为什么你觉得界限被跨越了，为什么你感到愤怒。我讨厌人们
outcome. So some final reminders. It is totally okay to feel angry. It's telling you something. It is just a sign of something. You don't always need to forgive. You don't always need to have an answer to your anger, but you can't suppress it. You have to find a way to either process it through communication, through talking it out, through the 30-30 intervention, or channeling it. Finding how you can find a medium or an outlet for this anger instead of letting it sit in the body. I think you are not an angry person just because someone has crossed your boundaries or repeatedly crossed your boundaries. You're not an angry person because society and your parents and your family and everyone
的现实被抹杀，仅仅因为他们情绪化，而这正是我们这一整集一直在讨论的事情。这种情绪并不可耻。它不是坏事，但当你让它做出故意伤害他人、不假思索地伤害他人、或者让你无法从情况中真正获得所需的事情时，它就是坏事。所以我认为，在这里与愤怒建立健康的的关系以及向他人表达愤怒的方式非常重要，这样我认为它才能成为一种工具，而不是障碍，并且在其他情况下，它真的可以帮助激发改变。它可以帮助激发进步，促进你与他人之间更好的理解，或者带来更好的结果。
around you has told you to hold on to that anger and not let it go, has told you to be polite and suppress it. There are a lot of positive ways that this emotion can help us. It can help us in our relationships, in our careers, in our lives in general. So I hope this episode has helped you, especially if you have a long-term relationship with anger. I hope that it's at least taught you something new, that you've learned something about yourself or about the psychology. I found it really fascinating because I think about anger a lot and I think about anger in my life and anger in my family's life and, you know, sometimes it's like very easy to just hide from it and it's very easy to go off and rant, but I've found that that doesn't always leave me actually
所以一些最后的提醒。感到愤怒是完全正常的。它在向你传达某些信息。它只是某种信号。你并不总是需要原谅。你并不总是需要为你的愤怒找到答案，但你不能压抑它。你必须找到一种方法来处理它，可以通过沟通、通过倾诉、通过30-30干预法，或者通过宣泄。寻找如何为这种愤怒找到媒介或发泄口，而不是让它留在体内。我认为你并不是一个爱生气的人，只是因为有人跨越了你的界限，或者一再跨越你的界限。你并不是一个爱生气的人，因为社会、你的父母、你的家庭和周围的每个人
feeling better. So hopefully you've taken that with you as well. As always, if you've enjoyed this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. Make sure you give us a follow on Instagram at that psychology podcast, especially if you have an episode suggestion or something that you want to say about this episode. I would love to hear from you. We're always taking ideas and feedback and make sure you're just having a good time. I don't know where I was going with that, but make sure you're happy. Here's like a little reminder to just take a second right now. Ask yourself, am I happy? What could I do about it if I'm not? That's a beautiful way to end the episode.
都告诉你紧抓着愤怒不要放手，都告诉你要做个有礼貌的人并压抑它。这种情绪有很多积极的作用，可以帮助我们。它可以在我们的关系、我们的职业、我们的整体生活中帮助我们。所以希望这一集对你有所帮助，特别是如果你长期与愤怒相伴的话。我希望它至少教给你一些新的东西，让你对自我或心理学有了新的认识。我觉得这真的非常迷人，因为我经常思考愤怒，思考我生活中的愤怒、我家人生活中的愤怒，你知道，有时逃避它非常容易，发牢骚也非常容易，但我发现这并不总能真正让我
Hopefully we will see you back here next week with another one. On The Look Back at it podcast. In 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
感觉更好。所以希望你也能把这一点铭记在心。一如既往，如果你喜欢这一集，请随时在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你现在收听的任何地方留下五星好评。确保在Instagram上关注我们，账号是that psychology podcast，特别是如果你有剧集建议或者有什么想对这一集说的话。我很乐意听到你的声音。我们一直在接受各种意见和反馈，确保你过得开心。我不知道刚才说到哪儿去了，但请确保你快乐。这里是一个小提醒，现在花一秒钟问问自己：我快乐吗？如果不快乐，我能做些什么？这是结束这一集的绝妙方式。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games.
希望我们下周还能在这里相见，收听另一期节目。在《Look Back At It》播客中。1979年，对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说也很重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。
This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct?
和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hardway》。
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Nanchini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped.
这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在任何地方真的都不安全，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在AHA广播应用程序、Apple Podcast或任何你获取播客的地方收听并学习艰难的方式。2023年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是一个骗局。埃伦女士，你对这个特定的测试动过两次手脚，对吗？
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
我动过一次测试的手脚。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·南奇尼。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身和建立韧性的科学。